[Música]
en bolivia este martes se registró la
octava jornada consecutiva de protestas
entre grupos de agricultores cocaleros
de la paz el descontento se apoderó de
cientos de campesinos enardecidos por el
nombramiento de un simpatizante del
gobierno el presidente luís arse como
jefe de la asociación regional de
productores de coca a pesar del pedido
de los vecinos para que cese la
violencia el conflicto continúa y por
ello le quiero dar la bienvenida a
nuestro segundo invitado el se llama
franklin pareja él es politólogo y
profesor de la universidad mayor de san
andrés de san andrés el profesor gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 que es lo que
realmente está pasando en el conflicto
de cocaleros en la paz en bolivia
bueno muchas gracias en principio a
ustedes por la gentileza como usted bien
mencionó estamos viviendo momentos
turbulentos de una convulsión social
propiciada por uno de los sectores
emblemáticos y más importantes que
existe en el país que es el sector de
cocaleros en la actualidad existe una
disputa porque hay una dirigencia que ha
sido reconocida por el gobierno pero que
es desconocida por otros sectores de los
cocaleros de la zona de los yungas que
es específicamente la que está en el
conflicto en este momento es importante
como dato mencionar para que conozca el
mundo entero que el último informe que
ha presentado naciones unidas en bolivia
ha hecho notar que ha habido un 15 por
ciento de incremento de la producción o
de las plantaciones de coca al mismo
tiempo hacer saber para tener un
contexto claro que en bolivia hay dos
son las productoras una es en el chapare
y otra es en los yungas en el chapare
que es las 6 federaciones del trópico de
las cuales el señor evo morales el
presidente sintomáticamente
94% de esa coca no pasa por los mercados
legales y al mismo tiempo en los yungas
que es una zona donde la coca que se
produce es apta y es óptima para el
consumo tradicional también en los
últimos años ha venido surgir ha venido
reportando un incremento en cultivo lo
cual obviamente configura un escenario
de una lucha intensa que podría estar
más vinculada a situaciones
absolutamente al margen de la legalidad
entonces no es simplemente una lucha de
dirigencias de que quieren recuperar una
sede o de que eventualmente pues están
disputando en la presidencia de lo que
es esta organización el trasfondo es
mucho más complejo es uno de los
problemas estructurales que tiene el
país boliviano porque definitivamente
pues la lucha por la erradicación de la
coca en las últimas particularmente en
la última década no se ha atenuado sino
simplemente eso quería hablarle el
profesor porque tengo entendido que son
aproximadamente 100 mil plantaciones de
coca en el país bolivia específicamente
usted está hablando que el 94 por ciento
de estas aproximadas 100.000
plantaciones de coca no pasan
precisamente por el mercado legal que
hace el gobierno boliviano para tratar
de erradicar estas plantaciones o pues
no permitir que esta coca se use para
fines de la elaboración de la pasta de
la cocaína
este dato que le acabo de mencionar fue
emitido por el representante en bolivia
de naciones unidas de lucha contra las
drogas y el delito el señor césar guedes
y lógicamente estos estudios siempre son
limitados porque no hay la posibilidad
de tener una información muy adecuada
con respecto al universo real no
obstante las recomendaciones hablan de
que se debería hacer un mejor monitoreo
entonces uno se pregunta realmente por
qué no se realizan las labores de un
control y un monitoreo más eficiente
porque hoy por hoy las plantaciones de
coca no solamente están en sectores
autorizados sino que inclusive están
expandiéndose a sectores que son áreas
reservadas o áreas protegidas entonces
la pregunta definitivamente surge porque
los niveles de eficacia para controlar y
monitorear adecuadamente esto no forman
parte de una política integral efectiva
y entonces ahí tenemos algunas
obviamente algunas hipótesis para
empezar es tratándose de un sector
emblemático los cocaleros de los cuales
el expresidente morales es presidente de
las federaciones más grandes de bolivia
pues lo que se tiene es que las
plantaciones del sector de los yungas y
los cocaleros de los yungas nos han sido
tradicionalmente adherentes al proyecto
político y a la línea política del señor
evo morales entonces esta disputa es una
disputa intensa que se viene realizando
hace mucho tiempo y su principal
dirigente franklin gutiérrez hoy por hoy
está encarcelado entonces la disputa
lógicamente no es únicamente por la
presidencia por una sede sino que el
trasfondo de todo esto es mucho más
complejo pero no se tiene una
información verdaderamente clara al
respecto y lo que se manejan son
hipótesis quien tendría que
transparentar esta información
indudablemente pues tiene que ser el
gobierno ahora el gobierno si se ha
querido involucrar en involucrar hasta
ahora en esta semana que tiene este
conflicto digamos con las protestas
encendidas en la calle que ha dicho el
gobierno del presidente luís arce y
también hay otro
en este conflicto no hablo de armin él
es presidente de una facción de la
asociación de productores de coca de la
paz ellos están en contra pues de este
nombramiento del nuevo presidente pero
también dicen que el gobierno tiene
infiltrado a ciertos actores para que
desvirtúen la protesta que ellos están
haciendo que desierto hay sobre esto
bueno ciertamente hay una
facción o por lo menos un grupo de
dirigentes que han sido de reconocidos
explícitamente en una conferencia de
prensa donde estuvo presente el ministro
de gobierno boliviano entonces tenemos
que entender claramente que a de coca
que es la asociación departamental de
productores de coca es una institución
privada que no tiene en todo caso por
ningún motivo que tener actividades
inclusivas o injerencistas por parte del
gobierno el gobierno obviamente regula
la política de control pero el hacer una
manifestación explícita de apoyo a un
sector y el desconocimiento de otro
sector es lo que tiene prácticamente en
vilo a toda la sociedad en este momento
y lo que se tendría que hacer yo creo
que es nuevamente que entablar un
diálogo y una negociación
efectiva con un alto nivel de voluntad
política porque esto no presenta visos
de tener una solución y más bien parece
recrudecerse y en a medida en que el
gobierno por fin en apoyar a un solo
sector en contra de una gran aparente
mayoría obviamente este conflicto social
no parece que vaya a terminar y más bien
parece que se va a complicar en
consecuencia tiene que haber una
deposición de intransigencia y el único
mecanismo que se conoce en todo el mundo
pues es el diálogo y no parece haber una
mesa de diálogo propiciado por el
gobierno para dar una solución profesor
franklin esto hace tambalear de alguna
manera al gobierno del presidente volví
a analizarse
es un conflicto muy complejo el
presidente hace siempre esta última
temporada o este último tiempo no da una
señal clara ni explícita de tratar de
atenuar los conflictos y entonces estos
pues toman un rumbo cada vez más extremo
e indudablemente que afecta a su gestión
indudablemente que puede generarle más
problemas y por lo tanto yo creo que
todavía estamos a tiempo de que las
autoridades y también la radicalidad de
la dirigencia cocalera encuentren vasos
comunicantes para tratar de darle un
final y una solución a esto pero en la
medida también de que los intereses y
como te digo sobre todo esta impronta
radical se deviene ricamente de una
hipótesis que es la vinculación de que
el gran parte de la coca boliviana
estaría dirigida como materia prima a la
producción y otra pues el profesor
franklin gracias por su análisis por
explicarnos un poco no al contexto e
internacional nosotros como lo vemos día
fue qué ocurre en bolivia que como lo
dijo es una situación bastante compleja
y no simplemente es lo que se habla de
superficialidades con el cambio de
presidente en esta asociación de
cocaleros en su país en bolivia gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa en france 24 nos vemos en una
próxima oportunidad que tenga usted un
feliz resto de día y de esta manera
entonces nosotros terminamos con nuestro
segundo invitado del día estábamos
hablando con el profesor franklin